[Musique]
l'halloween aura lieu dans quatre jours
et puis parmi toutes les créatures
associés à la fête de celle qui nous
suit depuis longtemps
c'est ce sont les fantômes on les
retrouve dans plusieurs histoires
d'horreur certaine personne n'y voit
plus que des mythes et croire réellement
à l'existence de ces revenants et bien
c'est l'objet de notre chronique science
avec renaud mary guerre a gagné ils font
jour renault bonjour il devait sortie
des études très sérieuses pour nous en
parler oui je les préviens je voulais
profiter de l'halloween pourra parler
parce que c'est vrai que le reste du
temps ça fait pas très sérieux
mais il ya quand même un certain nombre
de personnes qui croient sincèrement ans
et ce genre de phénomène paranormal
il faut se dire que ça nous est tous
déjà arrivé au moins une fois que l'or
on est seul dans une pièce on fait des
choses peut être d'un coup comment
savoir le sentiment de malaise on a
l'impression qu'on est pas
nécessairement seul qu'une autre
présence avec nous de notre imagination
embarque puis on se met à avoir peur
donc notre cerveau est conçu pour
détecter les menaces alors c'est sûr que
si on se met à chercher des fantômes
il ya des bonnes chances qu'on en trouve
ou qu'on imagine mais en dehors de notre
imagination dit chaque histoire de
fantômes ça peut avoir une explication
qui lui est propre c'est vrai que ça
reste difficile de faire la vraie
science avec tout ça mais elles existent
et les études qui ont été faites sur le
sujet nous ont appris beaucoup plus sur
comment notre cerveau fonctionne que sur
les fantômes et bien justement c'est
quoi le mécanisme pourquoi ou comment le
cerveau pu nous donner l'impression
qu'ils attendent c'est un point qui
revient souvent c'est cette espèce de
sentiment d'une autre présence avec nous
et you une région du cerveau qui gère
cette sensation là ça s'appelle le lobe
pariétal et elle sert entre autres au
phénomène qu'on appelle la
proprioception ça c'est la capacité de
ressentir sa propre présence dans
l'endroit où on est c'est ce qui fait
que j'ai pas besoin de regarder mes
jambes en ce moment pour savoir où est
ce qu elles sont ou que je peux pas me
chatouiller moi même parce que je sais
que séné bras qui me touche mais comme
n'importe quelle partie du cerveau cette
région le peut aussi faire des erreurs
et en 2014 ya des chercheurs qui ont
fait une étude où est ce que là ils ont
réussi à recréer ce sentiment de près
d'autres présences dans une pièce vide
pour leurs cobayes avec un système qui
trompait cette espèce de sensation de
présence de présence du swatch et leur
chaleur le participant est ici les
fantômes c'était pas une présence
paranormal
les participants
santé seulement leur propre présence
mais au mauvais endroit dans la pièce et
ça peut avoir l'air étrange mais au
moment où c'est arrivé c'était sacré est
vraiment des sensations réelles pour eux
avaient certes et ont tellement eu peur
qu'ils ont voulu arrêter l'expérience
après coup ils sont fait expliquer puis
tout le monde trouvait ça drôle
mais ce qui est intéressant que cette
étude leur sexe que les chercheurs ont
montré que cette région du cerveau
pourraient être affectés par d'autres
choses de la vie quotidienne donc des
émotions intenses un stress la fatigue
tout ça ça fait jouer sur cette
perception là il des fouets et à être à
la source de cette de cette sensation
présence peut des fois arrivés chez des
personnes qui et puis les personnes qui
disent vraiment avoir vu un fantôme
c'est dû à quoi
ça s'est passé c'est sûr que plusieurs
possibilités mais les personnes qui
croient sincèrement avoir vu ça peut
arriver par exemple imaginez vous êtes
en plein milieu de la nuit vous vous
réveillez et là vous n'êtes pas capable
de bouger qui à côté de vos yeux une
grande créature vraiment terrifiant vous
n'avez pas vu si jamais vous l'avez
jamais vu de votre vie l a7 s'en prendre
à vous plaît de quoi disparaît et vous
reprenez contrôle de votre corps à ce
moment là mais si vous êtes comme 8% de
la population ça c'est un phénomène qui
s'appelle la paralysie du sommeil et
c'est que c'est un phénomène qui arrive
quand on dort pendant la période où on
fait des rêves qui s'appelle le sommeil
paradoxal c'est un moment où le cerveau
est aussi actif que à n'importe quel
autre moment de la journée complément de
la joie qu'on est actif la différence
est que tous les toutes les connexions
toutes les signaux qui sont censés se
rend là nos bras nos jambes eux mon
poste rendre ils vont être bloqués pour
nous éviter de bouger pendant notre
sommeil mais il ya certains phénomènes
des fois le stress l'alcool le manque de
sommeil ou une émotion intense qui peut
un peu déboussolé notre système du
sommeil et faire que le processus est
décalé qu'on va se réveiller en plein
milieu de la nuit sans toujours dans cet
état de paralysie dans lequel notre
corps est maintenu et il va y avoir une
période où les deux éléments vont être
mélangés notre cas nous rail vont suivre
notre personne dans la réalité on va
commencer à voir ce qu'on voit dans nos
rêves dans la pièce autour de nous et
c'est un phénomène temporaire mais qui
peut être vraiment effrayant pour les
personnes qu'ils vivent et meurent aux
enfants ça arrive aux enfants ça peut
arriver aux adultes aussi c'est pas ça
peut arriver à plusieurs personnes dans
notre vie à plusieurs raisons pour ça
mais c'est un phénomène qui existe et
qui peut expliquer en partie les
fantômes qu'on peut voir et ceux qui
croient en voit réveiller ça il peut y
avoir beaucoup d'explications différents
pour cela une qui revient souvent
sa vie nous apparaît électronique il ya
certains appareils qui peuvent
volontairement ou accidentellement
émettre des bruits à des fréquences
inaudibles pour notre rayon les entendre
pas mais dans quelle fréquence très
basses on plante on appelle ça des
infrasons mais c'est pas parce qu'on les
entend pas que ce sont le n'existe pas
et saison saison devront se déplacer
dans l'air comme des vagues à la surface
de l'eau et si on est proche de la
source de l'objet qui aimait ce sont là
cette énergie là pour faire vibrer notre
corps de façon imperceptible un tout
petit mouvement cendres même pas compte
mais les études montrent que c'est assez
pour créer un sentiment de malaise sur
des personnes et même créer des
hallucinations
certaines personnes à côté c'est sûr ça
peuvent voir des mouvements juste à
l'est ou d'exemples juste à la limite de
leur vision périphérique et c'est ce qui
pourrait expliquer dans certains cas des
fantômes il ya beaucoup d'autres
explications mais ça c'est une de celles
qui reviennent plus souvent intéressants
et merci beaucoup de vous êtes prêté au
jeu ce matin renault